let's talk about proportionality
proportion
portionality
all this means if we say that two
variables are proportional it just means
that they are constant multiples of each
other so this is so if we say that y is
equal to 3 times x we can say that y
is and we can be a little bit more
specific we could say y is directly
proportional y is directly
directly
proportional
proportional
to x
to x and of course we could divide both
sides of this equation and we would by 3
and we would get 1 3
y is equal to x so once again x is a
constant multiple of y we could write
this as x is equal to 1 3 y so we could
also write that x
is
directly
directly
proportional proportional
to y if y is directly proportional to x
then x is also directly proportional to
y by a different
proportionality constant
so this term right here this is the
constant of proportionality between y
and x or between x and y this is the
constant of proportionality so in
general if i say
if i say that a
is
directly proportional
directly sometimes you'll just see it
written as a is proportional a is
directly
proportional
proportional
to b
in general from this statement we could
write
we could write that a is equal to some
constant
times b where this constant is
equivalent to that constant or that
constant it's equal to some
number and you could also say that b is
directly proportional to a where you
know if you divide both sides of this
equation by k you would get b is equal
to 1 over k
a
this is direct proportionality
now another thing you might see and
we'll see it later in this video
is
being inversely proportional so let me
draw a little line here
let me draw a little line here so let me
give you a few examples of inverse
proportionality let's say that
y
is equal to
5 times 1 over x
notice what's going on here in this
situation y is proportional to the
inverse of x right or you could say that
y
is
inversely
inversely
proportional i'll just write i'll
abbreviate it proportional to
x it is directly proportional to the
inverse of x so here here is our
proportionality constant but it is
directly proportional to the inverse of
x here's another example and i'm just
playing with letters here i could write
a is equal to
10 over b
once again a is inversely proportional
to b you could rewrite this as a is
equal to 10
times 1 over b
a is proportional to the inverse of b or
it's inversely proportional to b so now
that we have that out of the way let's
do some examples using our our newly
found
knowledge of direct proportionality and
inverse proportionality
so here i have
a problem it says that
x is proportional to y
so we that means that x is equal to some
constant times y
and just so you're familiar with other
notation that you might see and when
you're talking about proportionality
other ways to write this statement here
x is proportional to y you could write
it like this x is equal to some constant
times y
or you could write it as
x is proportional to y that little
i don't know left facing fish looking
thing means proportional this and this
mean the same thing this means that x is
equal to some constant times y or
sometimes you'll even see it x squiggly
line y x is equal to some constant times
y this this and this and that are all
equivalent statements but this is the
most useful because say oh there's some
constant maybe we can solve for that
constant
then the next statement here says x is
proportional to y and inversely
proportional to z
so that second statement says that x is
equal to k
let me it's going to be a different
constant not necessarily the same
constant so let me put a different well
i'll call it k2 i'll call this k1 is
equal to some other constant not
necessarily some other but i'm guessing
it's going to be some other constant
times the inverse of z
times 1 over z that's what inversely
proportional to z means and other ways
we could write this is x is
proportional to the inverse of z x is
inversely proportional z or x is
inversely proportional to z these things
in orange are all equivalent i just want
to make you familiar with it in case you
ever see it
and then they tell us
they tell us okay x is proportional to y
inversely proportional z we wrote that
already and x is equal to 2 when y is
equal to 10. so let's do that
x is equal to 2 when y is equal to 10.
so x is equal to 2
when
k1 is multiplied by y that's what that
statement tells us and y is 10 when k1
is multiplied by 10 x is 2 when y is 10
i just put those numbers in there and
then we can actually use this now to
solve for k1 but before that let's see
what this next statement tells us it
says x is 2 when y is 10 and z is 25 so
x is 2
x is 2 when k 1
is multiplied sorry when k 2
when k 2 this k 2 is multiplied by 1
over z when or 1 over 25
so that's what that second statement
tells us so they say find x when y is
equal to 8 and z is equal to 35. so
essentially what they're asking us hey
why don't you use this information that
we gave you in the green and the red
solve for the different proportionality
constants and then use that to
write i guess the specific equations for
the proportionality or the inverse
proportionality and then solve for y or
z let's just do it
so here up here in green let me rewrite
it over here we know that x is 2 when y
when k1 is multiplied by y where y is
10. divide both sides of this equation
by 10
divide both sides of this equation by 10
you get 2 over 10 is one-fifth you get
k1 is equal to one-fifth so that tells
us that this first equation right here
i'll write in that original color is x
is equal to
5
y
now that second statement in red
we know that 2
2
is equal to k 2
times 1 over 25 let's multiply both
sides of this equation by 25
this cancels out and we we're left with
k2 k2 is equal to
50.
k2 is equal to 50 so we can write this
equation right here that x
is equal to 50 times one over z or is
equal to
50
over z so we've now solved for the two
constants of proportionality for these
two equations so now we can answer the
second part of this question find x when
y is equal to 8 and z is equal to 35. so
the situation when y is equal to 8 we
just go right here
x is equal to
1 5 times eight which is equal to eight
over five so that's what x is equal to
when y is equal to eight
when z
is equal to
thirty-five once again x is equal to
fifty over z is equal to 50
over 35 and let's see we can divide the
numerator and the denominator here by
5 so we get 10
over 7. so when z is equal to 35 we get
10 over 7 when y is equal to 8 x is
equal to 8 over 5. so those are our two
answers right there let's do another one
ohm's law
ohm's law states that current flowing in
a wire is inversely proportional to
resistance of the wire
so current
flowing in a wire is inversely
proportional to resistance of a wire so
let's use i for current
i is equal to current and we'll use r
for resistance
r is equal to resistance
and you might be wondering why i picked
i but later on when you start studying
electricity and maybe you become an
electrical engineer you'll see that i is
the conventional
letter used for current and i won't go
into the details of y just yet but it
tells us that current
that i is inversely proportional to
resistance so that first statement i
underlined in yellow says that current
is inversely proportional it's equal to
sum constant
times the inverse of
resistance is inversely proportional to
resistance of the wire
if the current is 2.5 amperes when the
resistance is 20 ohms so the current is
2.5
when
k
is multiplied by 1 over a resistance of
20 ohms 1 over
20 ohms and i'm assuming because they're
going to keep the units in amperes and
ohms later on so we could write you know
we could write m we could write the
units here if we wanted to but i'll keep
it simple and not write the units they
ask find the resistance when the current
is 5 amperes so this first statement
right here the current is 2.5 amperes
when the resistance is 20 ohms that's
this equation right here
right here so we can use this to solve
for k you multiply both sides of this by
20
multiply both sides of this by 20 these
cancel out and you're left with k
is equal to what's 20 times
2.5 20 times 2 is 40. 20 times 0.5 is 10
so it's going to be 50 40 plus 10. so k
is equal to 50. so in this situation
this equation is
i
i is equal to 50 times 1 over r or 50
over r that's our relationship
right there and then they ask find the
resistance when the current is 5 amperes
find the resistance when the current
is 5 amperes so when our current is 5
ampere so 5 is equal to 50
over
the resistance let's multiply both sides
of this equation by the resistance and
you get
5
r is equal to 50 right i just multiplied
both sides of this equation by r
these cancelled out so i got 5 r is
equal to 50. divide both sides of this
equation by 5.
we get r is equal to 50 divided by 5 is
10. so the answer is when the current is
5 amperes the resistance will be equal
to 10
ohms
and we could write it like this
10
ohms just like that let's do one more
one more
the intensity of light is inversely
proportional so the intensity of light
is inversely proportional to the now
let's be careful here to the
square
of the distance
to the square of the distance between
the light source and the object being
illuminated so let's just say
let's say that let's say
well we could use i again let's say i is
equal to intensity
intensity
of
light
and let's say that
d
d i'll do a different color
d is equal d is equal to the distance
between
between the light source
light source
and object being illuminated and
object so that's what d the distance
between the light source and the object
being illuminated now what does this
first sentence tell us the intensity of
the light is inversely proportional so
the intensity of the light i
is inversely proportional so it's going
to be some proportionality constant
times the inverse times the inverse but
notice the intensity of light is
inversely proportional to the square of
the distance not just to the distance so
to the square of the distance so to
distance squared if it just said to the
distance we would just have a d here but
it says the intensity of light is
inversely proportional so one over the
square of the distance between the light
source and the object being illuminated
so that's what this first stat statement
is going to give us this equation right
here
now they tell us
a light meter that is 10 meters so
they're saying when distance is equal to
10 meters a light meter that is 10
meters from a light source registers 35
lux so when the distance is equal to 10
meters they're telling us that the
intensity the lux is a measure of
intensity the intensity is equal to 35
lux
so what is the intensity what intensity
would register 25 meters from the light
source so this first statement they gave
us that i'm i wrote down the information
in this purple color we can use that to
solve for the proportionality constant
and then once we have that constant we
can solve for i or d's given one one or
the other
so that statement told us
they told us that when d is equal to 10
i is equal to 35 so i is equal to 35 so
35 is equal to
k
times 1 over
d squared 1 over 10 squared or we could
say
that 35
is equal to
k
times 1 over 100 multiply 10 squared
just a hundred multiply both sides of
this equation by a hundred
these cancel out
and we're left with k
is equal to what is this three thousand
five hundred
three thousand five 500. so we've solved
we've used this statement here where
they gave us some values to solve for
our proportionality constant so now we
know that the equation is the intensity
is equal to
3500
is equal to 3500 that's k over or times
1 over d squared or you could just write
over
d squared
now they say what intensity would it
register 25 meters from the light source
so they're saying d is 25. so intensity
is equal to 3500
divided by
divided by 25 squared our distance is 25
meters so the intensity the intensity
is going to be equal to 3 500
3500 divided by
well actually let's just keep it simple
let me see if is this well this is this
is divided by 25 times 25 that's 625.
let's just get the calculator out
so we get it's going to be 3500
divided by 25 times 25 which is 625
which is equal to
5.6
so it's equal to
5.6
lux which is the unit for light
intensity hopefully you found that
useful